this song Roxanne was when probably
everybody first heard of you it's about
a prostitute you imagine what it would
be like to be with a prostitute well to
have a relationship with a prostitute
right and is it one of those songs that
takes you a long time to write no we
were in Paris with the early version of
the police and we were staying in a very
very cheap motel in a very sort of seedy
part of town and in the street were all
these you know Beldon we ladies of the
night yes and I'd never been exposed to
that and I was kind of fascinated by I
couldn't afford one right so I kind of
conjured one up in my room it has a
Roxanne Ryan turn I thinking well what
would it be like to actually be married
to one of these girls by the way right
here in the beginning I should point out
you were recording the song you fell
over the piano a piada was right behind
me
and I just I just kind of relaxed I
thought the lid was down yeah and the
lid wasn't down and I played a chord
with my ass you're asking the record and
then I start laughing yeah because right
at the beginning I hear that laugh and I
hear that shitty chord which works so
great everybody knows it but if you
listen carefully right now that's your
ass hitting the piano so here you're a
guy who's an unknown the first time you
hear this on the radio where are you I
remember that I was painting my my
kitchen in I had a basement flat in
Bayswater in London and my little son
was on the floor I was up some ladders
painting some white emulsion on the
ceiling yeah the Radio 1 and then that
song came on yeah and I started singing
and I'm a [ __ ] Oh Rick do